那我觉得人生啊就是取舍，
我的身体健康这个是排在第一位的，
然后就是我的愿望，
如果我从愿望上来说的话，
我是想做妈妈的，
那可能我错过了这个时机了，
我这辈子就很难再做妈妈了，
所以我今年29岁，
我对象呢，
她是31岁找到我，
是一个带货主播，
我现在是未婚未育，
我们认识挺多年了，
但是以前不熟，
最近恋爱的话是差不多将近快两年左右，
我们两个都是农村家庭，
没房没车，
没附加，
就是我手里的存款大概是40个左右。
对前面说我声音难题，
因为我早上起床还没开始直播的声音会比较嘶哑一点点，
就现在你的声音都算是不错了，
有好多主播那个声音都哑的好可怜，
哦呀，
完全不像自己以前的声音了，
这个点你要注意啊，
还是要带好嗓子啊，
好，
你接着说啊，
我想跟我对象明年结婚，
然后我父母的话，
目前算是比较康健，
可以带孩子，
但是我们都是异地，
我家里面有我跟我妹妹她差的很远，
所以说接下来父母呢，
就是我要负责，
但是我的父母也在外地，
我也在外地要打工和工作，
我是一个中专学历啊，
16岁的时候开始去公司做柜姐，
然后18年的时候开始做主播，
卵巢早衰，
就让我早点休息，
所以说我就放弃了晚上的工作，
就继续去。
白天去直播，
当时收入就略有下降嘛，
然后我就跟我的，
但是老板娘嘛，
两个人一起创业，
然后呢，
我们就一起搞二一年开始创业，
到二四年的时候就失败了，
就把我做主播存在那些年的几十万全部都亏完了，
就兜里面应该连最后一个月的工资差点要跟我爸妈借一点，
然后把我的团队的小伙伴的工资给付出去，
这个过程当中呢，
我就非常焦虑，
就出了一点点的肠道问题，
就有点长期拉肚子，
然后不太舒服，
那个时候呢，
因为实在太忙了，
也没有注意，
所以呢就到现在，
今年是二五年，
我的项目被公司回收了，
我是能够继续自己去做的，
但是我没有资金在支持我继续去做了，
所以我就选择了跟我的老板去谈，
谈了一个好的薪资和一个好的提成机制，
就做就开始打工了嘛，
所以项目被公司回收以后呢，
我就开始一直都是晚上直播，
这个过程当中我就发现我肠道问越来越严重，
又担心将来生孩子会遇到问题，
因为当时她说卵巢早衰是只是一点点，
但是呢不是很严重，
所以我又做了一次，
大概是2点几，
那个am Ms大概是2点几，
对对对，
2点几就略低，
但是呢还行，
我就想要说我这个肠道问题和这个我就先调整一下，
我试试白天播行不行，
然后我播了大概不到一个月，
流量也下滑，
业绩也下滑，
就导致我非常的焦虑，
我的老板想要稳住我这个项目不亏钱，
所以他。
就开了两个班次，
导致我的流量竞争压力就更大，
然后我就更加焦虑了，
我到底我什么时候生孩子合适，
还是我当下赶紧挣钱，
因为我当下算是我觉得人生的一个小机会，
我问一下你现在的时间，
你有男朋友吗？
就稳定的有对象，
我现在到底是第一个方案就是回去保住我的工作，
我就上晚班继续做，
我们打算明年要小孩嘛，
就把要孩子的这个计划往后再推一推，
这是第一个，
第二个我是直接播白天，
然后身体，
然后呢明年生孩子，
那我的工作很有可能就比较难拿到好的单次和好好的工资，
然后第三个呢，
就先搞到明年继续播这个晚上的直播，
如果怀上孩子了，
那就直接调整到白天直播，
所以说我就纠结我到底要生孩子还是先保住我的工作，
我这个真的最近很能焦虑这个问题，
就是如果AMH值是二点几了的话，
我觉得可能三十二十九岁本来是喜欢小孩的，
是不是对我们家就只有我和我妹妹，
所以首先我自己是很喜欢小孩的，
我对孩子这个事情是比较执着的，
那还是身体要紧，
身体比钱重要，
刚刚我看到有个姐妹说啊，
萌菲姐肯定是要先挣钱，
不是的，
人生的体验，
身体的健康，
我觉得是比挣钱要重要的，
所以我现在就也想听听大家的想法，
然后我到底什么时候去结婚和生爱比较合适，
就这个是我比较纠。
求，
到底要先把孩子给生了，
还是事业先为主，
喜欢小孩子，
也确实是想要孩子的话，
既然现在已经出现了卵巢早衰的迹象，
那先把这个人生大事解决掉，
因为我要孩子也比较晚嘛，
我那会儿也测了一下那个AMH值，
我印象中我的AMH值我都快40岁了啊，
我那会儿去测的时候都是大于二点几的，
嗯，
所以我的身体，
那我觉得人生啊就是取舍，
我的身体健康这个是排在第一位的，
然后就是我的愿望，
如果我从愿望上来说的话，
我是想做妈妈的，
那可能我错过了这个时机了，
这辈子就很难再做妈妈了。
咱有些话是这么说的啊，
就算他卵巢没有早衰，
现在正常的五六对夫妻里面就有一对是生育障碍的，
你知道吗？
这是实话，
就算整体是正常的，
五六对夫妻当中就有一对生育障碍，
更何况咱们现在是卵巢早衰，
好好的，
谢谢。
还有一个问题是我关于我对象的问题，
然况他今年是31岁，
然后呢，
他自己做自己的生意做的不大，
每个月大概月收入的话是1W左右，
那他做货嘛，
会有一些负债，
大概负债我帮他算了一下是10W左右，
就我们两个的情况，
就属于大家的收入都不是很稳定，
家庭都没有什么注意，
然后他自己本身情况的话，
他是很。
一家他我现在在房间，
他也在外面给我煮饭做饭，
就我晚都不行，
整体是对我个人来说，
我觉得还是比较合拍的，
就睡一个被窝也是挺合适的，
也没有什么大的争吵，
也很支持我工作，
然后也能答应小朋友也会给我信，
就如果说买房的话，
他的父母能够支持大概18不做，
也没有什么不良嗜好啊，
或者是一些不好的这些东西啊，
也是没有的，
所以就总就看似有点太过于完美了，
就有点遭虑，
我们打算年底结婚，
有没有什么隐患，
有没有什么需要注意的，
你这同事16岁就出来了，
在社会上摸爬滚打也这么多年了，
对，
就以你自己的看法，
你觉得他会是演的演了那么久吗？
还是说他本身就是愿意照顾人，
他愿意照顾你，
第一是我觉得他性格相对来说比较好，
但是第二我觉得也是会有一点点的这种迁就我的成分在里面，
因为我挣的相对来说会多一点点，
父母相处的怎么样啊，
他父母也是普通的这个农村家庭，
跟我父母相差不大，
他跟他的兄弟们关系是比较好的，
就家庭关系是融洽了，
他自己的，
你要让我现在看的话，
我是看不出来什么硬伤，
但是其实他并没有你所描述的这么好，
因为第一他工作也不是很稳定，
对对，
他并没有你所描述的这么好，
对吧，
有几位我说为什么亲戚。
我已经剖析过了，
我知道没有说是因为各种各样的不良嗜好，
也是因为这些年做生意，
因为我们是一个行业的，
就我理解比较有欠款这样的，
要结婚要过日子的话，
有很多程序式的东西是要履行的，
比如要查征信报告，
比如要做体检，
要查下有没有遗传性的疾病，
查一下祖上三代有谁有没有人精神方面的疾病，
要查一下这个有没有什么其他的传染性的疾病，
这些东西都要查一下的。
另外的话，
我觉得还是该履行的手续一样都不能少，
该订婚该给彩礼给彩礼是吧，
就是一样程序都不少，
就如果我们决定结婚的话，
因为当下我其实是不想买房子，
我跟他提，
他跟我讲，
我说不买，
他就是不买，
因为当下这种情况，
我们没孩子，
因为如果买了房的话，
我们又要租房，
又要装修，
又要还房贷，
还要养孩子，
我觉得压力太大了，
我想往后压几年再买，
孩子上学啊什么的会会出现问题，
因为这确实没经验，
这个也不存在的，
因为现在有很多地方的这个入学政策是租房子也是可以有社保，
也可以入学的，
不是说非得一定要有房子才能入学，
而且等孩子入学的话，
又是几年之后了，
如果现在不买房子的话，
那你就该要彩礼，
就要的稍微高一点，
十几万呀什么的，
要的高一点啊，
哇，
我都不打算要彩礼，
因为之前已经答应孩子给我姓了，
你为什么要孩子跟你姓呢？
你们家是有什么需求吗人。
就我跟我妹妹，
如果说没有孩子跟我姓的话，
我们他就没有这个姓氏的了，
你爸爸妈妈非死活要求这么干嘛，
也没有，
但是怎么说其实也挺没面子的吧，
因为我们那边对这个男生女生其实不是很看重，
所以我们家这两个女儿，
所以说就大部分会有一种就是这个男生上门的这种说法，
我就想着说能不能这个孩子跟我姓也很次，
其实坦率的说啊，
假率如果说实实在在给我10万块钱的彩礼和孩子跟谁姓这个事儿的话，
我要彩礼，
要彩礼能解决老大的事儿，
10万块钱能解决老大的事儿呢？
嗯，
供你参考啊，
好好，
就这样啊，
谢谢啊，
你记得点赞关注哦。